well I know you have a chart Michael on
story mastery calm that's incredibly
helpful and guess we can have a link to
it below the video here yeah I I know
right now I understand that on this
video we're cutting - a picture of this
chart but also if you'd like your own to
be able to download and you can kind of
follow along with what we're talking
about underneath the video you'll see a
link that goes to a page on my website
and then you can get your own PDF and
download that for free
and then as you're listening to the rest
of this you can follow along the chart
if you want to it's one that I develop
mostly for my lecturing so when I'm
talking to to a group of participants
they can sort of follow along with this
you know this through line or this
timeline of a movie as we look at each
of these six stages can you give us an
overview of the sixth stage plot
structure
just a quick Sana'a let me preface it by
saying this is what it's sort of built
on I mean my underlying philosophy of
all storytelling whether you're a
novelist or screenwriter movie maker TV
writer whatever it might be is that your
primary goal as a storyteller must be to
elicit emotion you must create an
emotional experience for the audience if
it's a movie or a play for the reader if
you're a screenwriter and you have to
get get it read so you can get the movie
made or if you're a novelist or whatever
so your primary goal has to be to create
emotion and this is a way to accomplish
that goal these are the this is sort of
the foundation of how you create that
emotional experience for the audience or
for the reader and so these six stages
are the six stages you're going to take
your hero through and also the audience
through as we go from the beginning of
the story to the end so the first of the
six stages what constitutes the first
10% of the story is what I call the set
up that's simply where we introduce the
hero you create an emotional connection
to that character you show her living or
everyday life then there's a turning
point the opportunity something new
happens that takes us into
second-stage that's the next 15 percent
of the movie or the script by the way
the percentages if novelists are
watching this are a little more fluid
you don't have to stick quite as closely
but in scripts there are one or two
pages on either side of these
percentages pretty pretty consistently
so the second stage the second 15
percent of the movie is what I call a
new situation your hero has now been
presented with some event that takes
them somewhere new it might be
geographically new or just some new
circumstance where they have to figure
out what's going on then something
happens at the one-quarter mark at the
end of Act one that is going to move the
character towards a specific visible
goal they are going to then declare and
begin pursuing a specific finish line
that they want to reach by the end of
the story my term for that is the outer
motivation for the character because
it's outwardly visible and it's their
desire so it might be to stop a serial
killer it might be to win the love of
the love interest in the movie whatever
now they begin pursuing that so they go
into act 2 and the first half of act 2
is stage 3 that's progress they
formulate a plan and the plan seems to
work and the obstacles start getting
bigger and bigger until finally at the
midpoint of that story they're going to
make a bigger commitment to the goal up
to that point they sort held one foot in
one foot out now they're going to reach
what I call the point of no return
something's going to happen that demands
of them that they sort of put both feet
in so they're going to devote everything
they can now to achieving the goal they
can't back up they burn their bridges
behind them so to speak so that moves
them into stage 4 which is complications
in higher stakes because the further end
of the story the character goes the more
is at stake because it the goal becomes
more and more important to them but also
the harder it is to achieve the goal the
outside world is going to start closing
and the bad guys going to discover that
the hero is after him
whatever it might be so it gets tougher
and tougher and tougher until at the
three quarter mark right at the end of
Act two the hero is going to suffer or
encounter a major setback something's
going to happen that destroys seemingly
any hope of achieving the goal the plan
is out the window the worst possible
thing that could happen happens and so
in response to that the hero will do two
things first the hero's going to retreat
and try and go back to the life they
were living at the beginning and give up
on the goal but that doesn't work
they're not satisfied they're not
fulfilled or they just can't give up
because somebody's life is at stake or
whatever so then they make one last
all-or-nothing do-or-die final push and
that's the Stage five which is the final
push it's putting everything on the line
giving every ounce of courage and energy
they have until they reach the final
turning point the fifth turning point
and that's the climax
that's where everything gets resolved
that's where the hero faces the villain
for the last time or the hero wins the
love of the love interest and they
decide they're going to live happily
ever after or whatever that climax might
be and then the sixth stage is what I
call the aftermath because we need to
see the new life that this hero that
this character is going to live having
completed this journey and that's pretty
much it it's it's like a before and
after picture starting out in an
everyday life going through this journey
to accomplish this goal and then in the
end seeing how their life has been
transformed because they took this
journey
you